you guys take music very seriously
there's no bullshitting around it's a
job and you take it seriously and you
guys always do great performances
and then all of a sudden you win five
grammys and here you were right before
covid
selling out madison square garden
and then everything stops then you have
to go back to the compound it's crazy it
was like a victory lap and then oh no it
can't they can't say it ain't so what
was that like for you and what was the
frustration there oh gosh it was such a
major interruption in that momentum you
know that i've been waiting for so long
you know to get i just turned 40 and i
was talking to bonnie raitt about this
because god i don't know about you but i
love bonnie ray i worship that woman
oh same everything about her it's just
like nobody can say a bad thing about
her she's so talented
right and she had this latter day
moment too this latter day success that
came
you know um when she was ready for it
and that's what i love about what
happened to me in the twins is we were
just ready you know we knew what to do
with the moment the adrenaline wasn't
going to get the better of us we were
just really ready to like to seize this
thing and then
you know coitus interruptus
[Laughter]
so how do you deal with that
psychologically i mean you know bonnie
rape was your psychotherapist and calmed
you down a little or what'd she say yeah
she's just got this great we talked a
lot through this kind of thing because
obviously you know
her momentum wasn't interrupted and she
went on to be um bonnie ray and it's so
funny you mentioned it because i have
this memory of like right before the
pandemic hit you know i always looked at
ticket sales i would get the email that
would say the ticket sales you know and
we used to play in
venues that were a third capacity
sometimes half capacity sometimes you
know big curtain closing off
the top of the theater and
and
i would always worry me and i would get
anxiety about it and you know you always
try to tell yourself you're going to
play for the people that are there but
it's tough you know so i would look at
these ticket sales and and um you know
those one or two sold out shows
uh a month would like really anchor me
you know emotionally and get me really
hyped and after that
whole thing right before the pandemic it
was like our ticket sales everything was
sold out it was just this row of sold
out shows and and all caps you know sold
out
and then they all went away they just
disappeared and i was like this is some
kind of cosmic joke but it happened to
everyone
you